perhaps the only thing more anticipated
on Super Bowl Sunday than the game
itself puppy monkey baby
are the commercials
you can't just wear my face and many of
the most iconic commercials are beer ads
from the funny how you doing how you
doing
to the poignant
but for 33 years these beer ads have had
one thing in common
[Music]
Anheuser-Busch inbev has been the only
company permitted to advertise alcohol
during the Super Bowl thanks to an
exclusivity deal with the NFL Budweiser
took full advantage of that agreement
and for the past two decades the Brewer
outspent all other brands in advertising
at the Super Bowl but this year
Budweiser is calling it Audible and
giving up its grip on the event and that
has opened the door to beer and alcohol
companies that have long been excluded
from the big game Anheuser-Busch giving
up their exclusivity on that game is a
huge deal
Super Bowls are consistently ranked as
the most watched annual television
broadcasts in America although ratings
have declined in recent years last year
the big game attracted over 112 million
viewers
according to the analytics firm cantar
there are approximately 80 to 100 ads
aired during each Super Bowl that works
out to a total advertising time of about
50 minutes or roughly 30 seconds per ad
purchasing a commercial during the big
game isn't cheap in 2022 each 30 second
ad slot went for as much as 6.5 million
dollars I got some bad news so after
previously paying for the privilege to
keep its competitors off the field why
is Budweiser changing course now how is
that supposed to sell beer even though
Anheuser-Busch Gave Over gave up their
exclusive right to be the only alcohol
Advertiser in the Super Bowl doesn't
mean that Super Bowl is not impactful
from a business point of view
Anheuser-Busch is still spending tons of
money during the game on ads and what
they've said publicly is that they're
basically going to use some of the money
that they use on that for other things
so when you think about Super Bowl it
happens in the middle of February it's
not really the prime selling season for
beer that happens in summer so you could
imagine that a company like a b might
save some of that money and spend it
when you know sales are really high
although Anheuser-Busch inbev has
effectively had a monopoly on Super Bowl
beer ads since 1989. other brands have
found creative ways into the
conversation surrounding the game such
as buying ad time in local markets
around the country beer brands have
really had to bend over backwards to try
and steal the buzz and they've for years
depended on these guerrilla marketing
campaigns to stimulate Super Bowl Buzz
without actually buying ads and it's a
fraction of the price and you're still
getting press and you're also seeing you
know seen in really big markets this is
the stunt designed to make you miss our
competitors at one of the really
successful guerrilla marketing campaigns
that a rival Brewer had run a couple
years ago was won by Miller Lite they
basically ran a contest where they
offered free beer for consumers
basically saying when they see an ultra
the Michelob Ultra ad to go to the web
and type in this extra long URL so
basically that's stealing the traffic
that other people would have been
searching for that brand and it got him
a lot of publicity leading up to the
game even though they didn't have a
Super Bowl ad in the game itself for
this year's Super Bowl viewers can
expect to see Spirit Brands like Remy
and Crown Royal whiskey peanut butter
what Crown Royal is seizing on the
opportunity to compete roller Dave Grohl
of the Foo Fighters is already being
featured in a teaser designed to elicit
interest in the big games ad spot the
egg carton so I think the biggest
beneficiary of anheuser-busch's change
will be Molson Coors the company
actually is really creative because
they've learned to sort of try and find
their way to steal the buzz and this
year they've used that creativity to
come out with this huge program
after an over 30-year Hiatus Molson
cores recently ran ads asking consumers
which of its two light beers Miller Lite
or Coors Light deserves the Brewers
coveted Super Bowl spot they've teamed
up with DraftKings which is really smart
given how you know everybody in this
nation is obsessed with sports online
betting right now so what consumers can
do is go and figure out like oh I think
this is what they're you know will it be
will it be Miller will it be Coors
oh hey Heineken will also make an
appearance this year the Dutch brand is
teaming up with Marvel to promote the
upcoming Ant-Man film and its
alcohol-free Brew Heineken 0.0
despite giving up its exclusivity
agreement with the NFL Anheuser-Busch
inbev Brands like Bud Light and Michelob
Ultra will still have a presence in the
game on February 12th who drinks
Budweiser but on the national stage
Budweiser won't be appearing they say
all people are Six Degrees of Separation
away from each other in Regional markets
Budweiser will run an ad that features a
Kevin Bacon voiceover with a nod to the
concept of Six Degrees of Separation all
facilitated by a six-pack the people who
share the same spirit
share the same beer
this bud's for you